[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
tortenwelt heute gibt's kein rezeptvideo
von mir sondern ich werde heute mein
Video über meine Küchenorganisation
machen ihr habt mich ja schon oft
gefragt wie ich meine Küche organisiere
wie ich sie eingeräumt habe und wie
einfach bei mir mein Zeitmanagement in
meinem Alltag aussieht und das ist ja so
ein ganz wichtiges Thema denn was ist
wichtig als unsere Zeit die Zeit ist ja
das einzige was man wirklich nicht
kaufen kann ich gehe zwar zur Arbeit und
werde dann von meinem Arbeitgeber für
meine Zeit bezahlt die ich eben
entgegenbringe aber ich kann noch so
viel Geld verdienen und ich kann mir die
Zeit nicht zurückkaufen deswegen ist die
Zeit wirklich das Wertvollste was wir
haben mein Mann und ich wir hatten uns
mal einen Artikel durchgelesen in der
Zeitung und zwar ging es darum da hat
eine
Krankenschwester sterbende befragt also
die die kurz vom Sterben eben waren und
hat gesagt was hättet ihr in eurem Leben
anders gemacht und eigentlich zu 100%
war immer die Antwort ich hätte gerne
mehr Zeit mit meiner Familie oder mit
meinen Freunden verbracht und da war
keiner da der irgendwie gesagt hat ich
hätte gerne noch die KitchenAid gehabt
oder eine Küchenmaschine gehabt oder ich
hätte mir gerne noch dieses Auto gekauft
oder hätte gern den Garten noch mal
gemacht es ging wirklich allen darum
mehr Zeit mit der Familie zu verbracht
zu haben oder mehr Zeit mit den Freunden
und ich möchte jetzt heute einfach so
ein bisschen auf das Thema
Zeitmanagement eingehen und möchte euch
ein paar Tipps auch geben wie ihr z.B
Euren Alltag organisieren könnt und dann
kann wirklich jeder von euch
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen Zeit sparen
jetzt ist das Thema Zeit sparen
natürlich bisschen blöd weil eigentlich
kann man keine Zeit sparen jeder Mensch
hat jeden Tag 24 Stunden egal ob arm
oder reich egal ob berufstätig oder
arbeitslos jeder hat 24 Stunden man kann
also keine Zeit sparen sondern man kann
sich seine Zeit nur richtig organisieren
und einfach managen und aufteilen und
wenn ich das richichttig kann kann ich
mir am Tag auch jeden Tag Zeit für die
Familie nehmen wir machen es z.B so dass
wir jeden Tag zusammen zu Mittag oder zu
Abendessen und wir unternehmen jeden Tag
irgendwas also entweder gehen wir
draußen spazieren oder wir gehen noch
mal auf den Spielplatz irgendwas einfach
um gemeinsam noch mal Zeit zu verbringen
und das kann wirklich jeder egal wie
hart oder wie viele arbeitet weil es
einfach drauf ankommt wo ihr was
einsparen könnt und die Zeit dann eben
für was schönes nutzen könnt natürlich
muss man dabei beachten man kann das
jetzt nicht verallgemeinern weil jede
Ausgangssituation ist anders oder man
hat mal stressigere Phasen oder
stressfreiere Phasen oh Gott wenn ich an
meiner Prüfungszeit zurückdenke ich
hatte ja gar keine Zeit für gar nichts
und war auch froh wenn ich dann mal ein
paar Stunden mit meiner Familie
verbracht habe weil ich einfach viel
gelernt habe und dann noch Haushalt und
alles aber das ist ja nicht immer so
dass man immer diese Stressphasen hat
und ein so kann einfach jeder egal aus
welcher Situation heraus kann bestimmt
seinen Alltag optimieren und einfach ein
bisschen mehrit Zeit einfach rausnehmen
für ganz viele schöne Dinge mit der
Familie oder mit den Freunden das
wichtigste für uns Menschen sind nämlich
die sozialen Kontakte denn was bringt
wenn ihr ein schönes Haus gebaut habt
aber keinen habt den ihr einladen könnt
oder was bringt wenn ihr die tollste
Köchin oder der tollste Bäcker seid
richtig leckere Sachen zaubert aber
keinen hab mit dem mir das zusammen
genießen könnt und deswegen müsst ihr
einfach schaffen euch ein bisschen Zeit
zu nehmen für die schönen Dinge und ich
habe es bei mir in der Küche so gemacht
dass ich meine Küche so organisiert habe
dass ich am Tag jeden Tag frisch kochen
kann aber eben so kochen kann dass ich
eben nicht zu viel Zeit in der Küche
verbringe mir macht es zwar viel Spaß
aber ich bin muss ich ehrlich sagen auch
noch viel lieber mit meiner Familie auf
dem Spielplatz oder wir nehmen uns dann
mehr Zeit zum Essen müssen da nicht
hetzen und jetzt zeige ich einfach mal
meine Tipps und zeig euch mal was ihr
euch vielleicht abschauen könnt
natürlich geht's jetzt heute in meinem
Video nur um meine Küchenorganisation
aber ich werde euch da auch mehrere
Teile draus machen denn ich zeige euch
auch mal wie ich meinen Vorrats Schrank
bzw mein vorratszimmer organisiert habe
oder mein Schlafzimmer also mein
Schlafzimmerschrank wie ich das Bad
organisiere oder das Wohnzimmer sod dass
ich eben jeden Tag viel viel Zeit
einsparen kann und ich verspreche euch
wenn ihr euch da die Tipps abgucken
könnt n so ein paar dann könnt ihr auf
jeden Fall mindestens bestimmt auch eine
Stunde pro Tag einsparen das heißt in
der Woche sind es 7 Stunden im Monat
sind es 30 oder 31 Stunden und aufs Jahr
gerechnet also man kann einfach ganz
viel Zeit sparen und dann habt ihr
effektiv viel mehr Zeit für eure
Freizeit aber jetzt hat er schon nicht
gerade gesagt man kann keine Zeit sparen
ja man kann keine Zeit sparen man hat ja
immer 24 Stunden aber ich kann die Zeit
eben bei der Arbeit einsparen und sie
für meine Freizeit und für meine
liebsten nutzen aber wir starten jetzt
einfach mal mit meiner Küche und ich
zeige euch die richtigen Tipps pro Tag
verbringt jeder Mensch in Deutschland
etwa eine Stunde 15 in der Küche da sind
jetzt Frauen und Männer mit dabei in
dieser Statistik und ich würde mal sagen
dadurch dass die Männer mit dabei sind
ist der Anteil der Stunden der Frau
etwas runtergesenkt und eigentlich
verbringen die Frauen ja viel mehr Zeit
in der Küche aber wir schauen jetzt dass
wir das so hinbekomm dass jede Frau oder
jeder Mann wirklich nur eine Stunde 15
in der Küche ist und nicht drüber
hinauskommt denn es gibt ja auch noch
schönere Dinge im Leben ich fange jetzt
hier einfach mal an mit meinem Vorrat
also ich gehe jetzt einfach die Küche
systematisch durch hier von rechts nach
links im uhrzeigesin oder so und zeige
euch einfach mal alles weil ihr wolltet
ja wissen was für Vorrat doen ich habe
was für Regale ich drin habe und so
weiter wer übrigens mein küchenvideo
noch nicht seht das verlinke ich euch
hier denn ich habe euch auch schon mal
ein küchenrundgang gemacht und werde
aber jetzt nicht auf die Küche eingehen
logischerweise ich habe jetzt hier
rechts zwei offene Regale und zwar habe
ich hier oben mein Müsli und meinen Tee
wir sind nämlich schwarzteetrinker und
deswegen muss es hier immer offen stehen
und unten dran habe ich meine Nudeln
abgepackt und auch meinen Würfelzucker
der gehört ja zum te mit dazu und ich
habe jetzt hier einfach alles offen
stehen weil wir z.B gerne morgens Müsli
essen und mittags einfach auch gerne
Nudeln essen und deswegen steht es jetzt
bei mir offen im Regal das heißt ich
kann einfach in die Küche kommen mir
mein müssli nehmen oder meine Nudel
nehmen und hab es dann einfach
griffbereit ich habe jetzt
warte ja ich habe meine Sachen hier in
diesem tuupdosen drin also in den
Behältern von tuupware die sind
durchsichtig das heißt ich müsste sie
gar nicht beschriften und weiß ganz
genau was drin steckt aber ich
beschrifte sie meistens trotzdem damit
mein Mann auch weiß was drin ist da habe
ich hier die Aufkleber von tupeware aber
die tausche ich jetzt bald aus ich
möchte sie nämlich einheitlich haben und
nehme mir da so ein Beschriftungssystem
und ich habe einfach auch diese Behälter
weil sie einfach dicht sind ich hatte
ganz früher auch mal neben den tuupdosen
auch günstigere Varianten die habe ich
mittlerweile alle entsorgt weil da
einfach das Problem ist dass sie nicht
dicht sind also ich hatte da ein paar
Gewürze auch mit drin mit so im Deckel
vielleicht erinnert ihr euch und die
waren einfach nicht dicht da ist mir
einmal so eine Dose runtergefallen und
alles lag auf dem Boden und bei diesen
turbbehältern weiß ich einfach sie sind
dicht sie sind zwar ein bisschen teurer
als andere das kann man schon dazu sagen
aber man hat einfach Qualität dann habe
ich hier meinen ersten Vorratsschrank da
sind all meine trockenen Vorräte drin
also alles was ich zum Backen brauch und
die habe ich alle auch in meinen
tubbehältern und was ich natürlich auch
bei den turbehältern gut
finde klar zahlt man bisschen mehr am
Preis aber wenn ihr z.B günstigere
Varianten nehmt aus z.B 1 € Shops da
sind einfach viele Weichmacher drin in
dem Plastik und das möchte man einfach
in dem Essen nicht drin haben hier habe
ich so sortiert dass ich hier unten
alles habe was ich immer braucht zum
Backen also meine Stärke Zucker mein
Mehl mein Kakaopulver oder Puderzucker
und oben drauf das
geht dann nach oben hinaus brauche ich
Dinge die ich gelegentlich brauche und
oben sind Sachen die ich selten brauch
wobei es bei mir jetzt keinen
Unterschied macht weil ich hier gut dran
komme aber auch oben gut dran komme also
ich komme da überall gut hin und das ist
ganz wichtig ich brauche kein Hocker ja
außer ich aber der Murat backt ja
nicht dann habe ich hier den zweiten
Vorratsschrank da habe ich jetzt zur
Hälfte nur noch die Vorräte und zwar
habe ich ich fange jetzt mal oben an
habe ich da mein Reis und meine Linsen
und so weiter oder meine Bulgur muss ich
noch beschriften da fehlt's noch weil da
der Murat oft ich weiß welcher Reis was
ist ich sehe es zwar aber ich glaube er
sieht es nicht so gell ja ich ich muss
ja nicht ich verbringe auch noch 15 ne
ich verbringe auch noch 5 Minuten in der
Küche und zwar Murat bring den Müll raus
einmal kurz den Müll holen und dann
wieder zurückbringen das war's und
Besteck ja und Besteck und hier habe ich
meine Gewürze das ist auch alles bei mir
auf Augenhöhe und zwar habe ich das
jetzt so sortiert ich werde hier noch
irgendwann ein weiteres Regal einbauen
hier dann kann ich nämlich diese hier
oben aufs Regal reinstellen und da ist
einfach wichtig ich habe viele Gewürze
und viele gewürzvorräte und mir ist es
einfach wichtig dass ich immer weiß was
ich habe die sind alle beschriftet und
ich kann auf einen Blick sehen was ich
habe hier oben sind jetzt Gewürze die
ich seltener brauch und da unten das ist
übrigens meine
puderzuckermühle und hier unten habe ich
die Gewürze die ich immer brauche also
thmian Oregano Minze Zimt natürlich wie
ihr mich kennt Salz und Chili mein
Pfeffer habe ich hier schwarzpfeffer und
buntpfeffer und hier habe ich so die
frühstücksvorräte und restgewürze das
habe ich jetzt auf so einem schönen
runden Drehteller das finde ich
natürlich richtig perfekt weil ich kann
ich muss da nicht nach hinten greifen
sondern kann das hier einfach drehen und
kann alles nach vorne holen und das kann
man z.B auch mit auf den Tisch stellen
das heißt wenn ich jetzt hier nur
frühstückssachen hätte könnte man das
komplette Ding nehmen und auf de
Frühstückstisch Stellen mal das habe ich
ja übrigens auch in meinem Kühlschrank
drin also ich finde das ist echt
Goldwert da habe ich jetzt auch noch ein
Tee drin den ich zurzeit
trinke oder Honig oder Erdnussbutter
übersichtlich du musst nicht immer
hinten reingreifen das ist genau musst
nicht immer nach hinten greifen und du
hast einfach sichtbar und ich find's
halt auch immer wichtig dass man seine
Schränke nicht überfüllt das heißt dass
man alles vollstopft dass alles
reinpasst sondern es muss ja ein
bisschen Platz frei sein sonst weiß man
nicht was hinten drin steckt dann
verschimmelt euch das oder keine Ahnung
oft war bei mir auch die Frage da ich ja
viele Vorräte habe also hier eineinhalb
Schränke oder fast zwei Schränke mit dem
offenen wurde ich oft gefragt ob ich
denn nicht Motten bekomme aber ich habe
diese tuuperdosen und deswegen habe ich
auch keine Motten bei mir weil die
einfach dicht verschließen und ich kenne
das z.B von einer Freundin die hatte
immer alles in Tüten und hat dann nur
die Tüten bisschen verschlossen und
reingestellt und da bekommt er natürlich
Motten rein und in so Vorratsbehältern
passiert einfach gar nichts müsst ihr
nur aufpassen dass sie eben richtig zu
sind
gut
hier habe ich meine Sachen und mein
Zubehör für meine Kenwood Maschine also
sellis Werkzeugkoffer mein
Werkzeugkoffer sieht auf den ersten
Blick sehr viel aus und viele denken
jetzt vielleicht oh mein Gott wenn ich
mir die kenwur Hool dann habe ich da so
viel Zubehör dabei und es nimmt ja total
viel Platz weg aber es wird ja noch mehr
Platz wegnehmen wenn ihr jede Maschine
einzeln hättet also wenn ich jetzt eine
Küchenmaschine hier hab und dann noch
einen Mixer extra hätte dann noch einen
Entsafter extra hätte noch mal äh ein
Fleischwolf extra hätte und so weiter
und so habe ich einfach alles auf einen
Blick und da ist auch so die wichtigsten
Dinge sind unten und die anderen sind
einfach
drüber und meinen dritten und letzten
Hochschrank habe ich dafür genutzt um
unsere Gläser da reinzugeben und alles
was in dem Schrank ist hat alles mit
Getränken zu tun also hier haben wir
unsere Teegläser die brauchen wir
nämlich ganz oft hier haben wir unsere
Kaffeetassen und die habe ich alle auf
so schön schöne küchenschraninteiler
gegeben weil ich so einfach den Platz
optimal nutzen kann hier habe ich es auf
zwei Etagen hier habe ich es auf drei
Etagen die habe ich jetzt bei Globus
gekauft aber die gibt's bestimmt auch in
anderen Supermärkten da müsst Ihr
einfach mal reinschauen die finde ich
einfach immer relativ praktisch da kann
man auch so Töpfe drin stapeln und so
weiter das ist echt super drüber habe
ich dann unsere
Gläser und unsere Tassen und ganz oben
habe ich z.B so eine Teekanne die ich
immer benutze wenn ich ingw Tee oder
Früchtetee trinke und oben sind einfach
noch unsere Getränkeflaschen oder unser
Smoothie Mixer oder einfach noch so paar
Karaffen und Teekannen das sind so das
ist so unser getränkeschrank und immer
wenn der Murat was sucht was mit
Getränken zu tun hat weiß er er muss da
gucken ganz
logisch dann habe ich hier einen meiner
zwei Kühlschränke den kleinen und den
benutze ich ja für meinen Vorrat und
habe da oben noch ein Fach und in dieses
Fach da kommt man so schät dran und
deswegen habe ich da einfach nur meine
Küchenrollen drin die ich einfach da auf
vorrad gelagert habe ich habe gern
vorrad und hier ganz links habe ich noch
so Öffnungen und da habe ich einfach ein
paar Backbücher mit drin und meine
backordner wo ich einfach meine Rezepte
sammle und da steht es einfach so drin
und da kann man den Platz eben optimal
nutzen wenn man da so eine kleine Spalte
hat ich würde jetzt sagen wir machen
jetzt mit der arbeitstheke hier weiter
oder erst die Unterschränke machen die
Unterschränke zuerst genau machen wir
die Unterschränke
ich habe hier jeweils zwei und da drüben
zwei und zeig die euch jetzt mal das
sind jetzt meine großen Auszüge oh mein
Gott und da habe ich meine ganzen runden
tuerdosen drin also alles was rund ist
mit Deckel und hier geh wieder runter
und hier ist es ganz cool ich habe hier
so einen Einteiler der zwar nicht
perfekt in diese Schublade passt weil er
bisschen zu schmal ist aber ich kann
damit einfach die Deck bisschen Abteilen
damit da einfach nicht so drin
rumfahren da oben habe ich ja noch so
eine zwischenschublade und da sind meine
schirzen und meine Putztücher und alles
mögliche oder die abtrockentücher drin
alles was ich eben in der Küche
brauch und unten habe ich meine eckigen
V
Vorratsdosen da ist dann hier alles drin
und der untere Schrank ist etwas tiefer
weil der keine zwischenschublade hat
und deswegen passen da auch Sachen rein
die etwas höher sind und die Deckel sind
immer direkt an den Dosen dran also an
der genau die Deckel haben wir immer
direkt an die Dosen ich kenne zwar die
Deckel zu den Dosen aber so weiß dann
auch der Murat welche Dose zu welchem
deckelur ziemlich einer ist der schwer
vom Begriff ist ja nein das meine ich
nicht aber wenn ich die Sachen besorg
wei ich ja aber deine Zuschauer denken
das langsam schon ganz ganz K dann habe
ich meine Spülmaschine und hier unter
dem Waschbecken habe ich meine
Müllbehälter hier fehlt jetzt einer und
hier habe ich auch so ein abtrenner mit
drin und da habe ich einfach so die
vorratssachen wie z.B ich habe jetzt
z.B bisschen Spüli auf vorrad gekauft
damit ich einfach nicht so oft einkaufen
muss und es steht da alles mit drin mein
ganzes Putzzeug ihr müsst natürlich
drauf achten wenn ihr Kleinkinder habt
die da dran gehen dann dürft ihr sie
nicht unten lassen die Sachen also da
müsst ihr wirklich drauf achten bei uns
ist so der Schrank geht ziemlich schwer
auf und die Samira ist jetzt schon vier
und die geht da auch nicht dran aber
selbst wenn ihr wisst s gehen da nicht
dran bitte lasst die Sachen nicht unten
vor allen Dingen nicht wenn ihr so ähm
normale Türen habt weil das ist echt
gefährlich wenn da die Kinder mal dran
gehen und eine Flasche aufmachen wä es
nicht so
gut ja was habe ich da noch dann habe
ich hier noch so eine Ablage das war
jetzt natürlich mit in der Küche mit
drin da habe ich dann mein Spülschwamm
und hier so eine Kiste wo Sachen drin
sind und bei uns trennt man übrigens den
Müll jawohl das ist die Hausordnung ja
dann habe ich hier auf dieser Seite auch
natürlich eine Schublade und da kann ich
jetzt einfach oben drauf schauen und
sehe einfach welche Schalen habe ich da
und welche brauche ich einfach und kann
sie mir dann einfach
nehmen auch hier habe ich eine
zwischenschublade und hier habe ich so
Sachen drin wie Backpapier und
backfolien natürlich ich habe hier mein
Wachspapier oder meine Frischhaltefolie
meine Gefrierbeutel und alles einfach so
dass man alles sieht hier auch dieses
stretchies die coolen oder meine kleinen
Deckel oder meine Topflappen und alles
was ich eben hier brauche das ist auch
hier relativ logisch denn ich habe ja
hier mein Backofen und brauch mein
Backpapier in der Nähe vom Backofen und
auch meine Topflappen in der Nähe vom
Backofen und da müsst Ihr einfach
schauen dass immer alles dort ist wo ihr
es auch braucht deswegen habe ich
übrigens auch meine Vorräte hier in den
Hochschränken weil meine kitchenid ja
auch hier steht und meine kW da drüben
und wenn ich dann backe dann mache ich
ja nicht so wenn ich alleine bin ohne
Kamera mache ich es nicht so dass ich
die Sachen in Schälchen Abwege und da
vorne back sondern ich back dann hier
hinten und rühre mir das hier zusammen
und wieg mir dann einfach die Sachen
direkt aus der Schüssel in meine Schale
rein und stell es dann wieder weg und
dann habe ich eben Zeit gespart weil ich
nicht noch kleine Schälchen brauch ich
muss nicht hin und her laufen und habe
einfach alles griffbereit und hier unten
habe ich noch so Sachen wie solche t
und meine Backrahmen die runden und
eckigen und einfach so ein paar
festbdosen zum Mitnehmen ja und die
festbdosen Reichen mit Sicherheit aus
und die ganze Stadt und die ganze Straße
damit auszustatten oder ja also wir
haben ein paar man braucht große und
kleine fesperdosen und vergisst der
Arbeit genau der vergisst dann bei der
Arbeit
me arbeitskollegenmer aus das ist Murat
fesperdose die macht man auf und dann
kann man da oben was reinlegen und dann
hat er hier noch ein Fach kann man hier
z Obst und Gemüse reinmachen und unten
kann ich auch was reinmen so ein
Doppeldecker finde ich immer total
praktisch we einfach schön sortiert
ist dann gehen wir jetzt auf meine
Arbeitsfläche hier hinten und zwar steht
jetzt bei mir da hinten die kenbood
nebendran habe ich so ein paar Keksdosen
da habe ich jetzt schon ein paar
Weihnachtsplätzchen drin die ich schon
gedreht habe übrigens falls ihr euch
fragt was die Geschenke da oben sollen
das war auch für meine Weihnachtsvideo
und die starten natürlich ab Mittwoch da
kommen dann weihnachtsvideos und ich
habe es eigentlich nicht gerne wenn
Sachen auf der Arbeitsfläche rumstehen
aber hier hinten stört's mich nicht ich
habe da nur die zwei Sachen stehen und
bei mir ist einfach immer wichtig dass
ich meine Arbeitsfläche immer putzen
kann ich mag es einfach nicht wenn man
da Staub drauf hat oder Krümel und
deswegen muss es immer relativ schnell
gehen ich will das schnell einmal drüber
wischen können und habe deswegen auch
nur die zwei Sachen auf dieser Seite
stehen und weil ich ja da auch nicht
arbeite stört mich das da auch nicht ich
habe ja meine Arbeitsfläche hier vorne
an der Insel dann habe ich auf der
anderen Seite genauso einmal die
KitchenAid und auch eine Keksdose nach
der ich mich immer so oft frag die ich
auch so hübsch und rosa die verlinke ich
euch einfach in der Infobox und hinten
dran lade ich jetzt gerade noch mein
Akku auf aber das soll jetzt nicht
stören und hier drüben habe ich noch
eine
Brotbox die ist auch von tubovare und da
habe ich einfach Brot drin aber das ist
jetzt gerade
leer und ansonsten habe ich hinten nur
noch eine Küchenrolle die ich aber
eigentlich gerne hier hinhängen würde
aber da brauche ich noch einen Aufsatz
von Ikea und diese Stange im Hintergrund
die die ich da hingehängt habe das ist
übrigens eine von Ikea bzw das sind vier
also das oder ein 2 3 4 das sind
einzelne die man dahin hängen kann und
dann gibt's da diese Häkchen mit dazu
und da kann ich dann Sachen dran hängen
wie z.B meine kochblume habe ich da oder
meine Topflappen weil die brauche ich
echt oft und dann kann ich da hinten
einfach die Topflappen nehmen und direkt
an den Ofen gehen also immer griffbereit
oder ich hängt da auch mein Kabel auf
von der KitchenAid oder von der Kenwood
weil ich es nicht mag wenn die Kabel da
so überall rumfahren und diese Stange
ist total praktisch also normalerweise
mag ich haushaltssachen von Ikea nicht
so wegen der Qualität aber bei dieser
Edelstahlstange kann man echt nichts
falsch machen die ist wirklich auch
total stabil selbst Ikea kann nichts
falsch
machenel und da haben wir einfach so ein
tolles Zubehör mit dabei also ich hole
mir da noch diese Küchenrolle Aufhängung
die kommt dann irgendwie dahin und hier
habe ich noch so eine Ablage da habe ich
jetzt z.B so putzzubehör drin stehen das
ist jetzt eine von der pamper Chef und
da habe ich einfach mein Spülschwamm
drin oder meine kleine Bürste und so
weiter und das kann ich einfach da oben
abstellen dann steht's hier unten nicht
rum und ich habe da unten einfach nicht
so viel Unordnung Hal besserchuldigung
das ist halt besser als so eine
komplette Edelstahlfront weil die musst
immer putzen hier ist nur die Stange wo
du mal vielleicht mal drüber wissen mus
mus und vor allem ich glaube das ist bei
jeder Küche wo wo im Haushalt
nachrüstbar oder also das war ja einfach
wir haben diese Stange innerhalb von 5
Minuten 5 bis 10 Minuten haben dran
gehabt oder hast du dran gehabt ich habe
geb und ja und da find ich halt echt
praktisch da gibt so cooles Zubehör wie
z.B das hier da hatte ich auch ab und zu
mal den Schwamm drin das war auch ganz
cool oder da kann ich auch ein
Spülmittel reinstellen mit der Flasche
ich habe es jetzt hier unten wenn ich es
benutze oder ich habe hier diese
Kräutertöpfe die man aufhängen kann das
ist das Beste was man ein besten Sachen
gekauft haben die sind echt toll weil da
kann man einfach sich die frischen
Kräuter nehmen ich liebe
Pfefferminze kann Biss nchen Basilikum
haben
und bei so kräutertöpfen müsst ihr immer
drauf achten die könnt ihr im Supermarkt
z.B kaufen und dann könnt ihr ein
bisschen davon abzweigen und frisch
einpflanzen damit sie so ein bisschen
auseinander kommen weil die aus dem
Supermarkt sind meistens so dicht
bepflanzt dass die euch daheim einfach
kaputt gehen und wenn ihr das macht und
die z.B auch auf die Terrasse oder in
den Garten setzt dann habt ihr da
einfach ewig was davon und die wachsen
dann halt immer wieder nach hier müssen
wir sogar wieder ein bisschen Umpflanzen
weil sie wieder dicht wachsen aber das
ist schon ein anderes Thema so ich
glaube zur Arbeitsfläche da hinten muss
ich nichts mehr sagen dann stehe ich
jetzt hier vor meinen Backöfen wieso ich
zwei habe habe ich ja in meinem
küchenvideo schon gesagt weil ich
einfach viel Backe und das einfach zu
Hause brauche und ich habe halt da oben
noch so eine Abstellfläche jetzt kann
man sich überlegen das irgendwie
vollzustellen ich habe da jetzt paar
Dekoelemente drauf ich habe z.B diese
küchenwage die kann man zwar gut als
dekoratives Element benutzen aber man
kann sie natürlich auch verwenden die
wiegt bis 4 kg und hat auch eine echt
coole große Schale die gibt's natürlich
auch bei uns im Shop und ich verlinke
die euch einfach in der Infobox ich
finde es ist auch ein richtig cooler
Geschenkartikel weil einfach so schön
aussieht aber eben auch praktisch ist
und da gibt's dann auch diese
Keksdose so eine 3 in1
Dose und da kann man einfach Kekse
reinmachen und drei Stück direkt
aufeinander stapeln die hab übrigens so
ein Gummiring also die verschließen
wirklich ganz dicht
die Kekse müssen ja auch frisch
bleiben dann habe ich da einfach noch
meine bisschen meine Kerzen und
natürlich
hier cakes made with love und das finde
ich gehört immer mit in die Küche dazu
so ein bisschen Deko ich habe eine
offene Küche das heißt die ist für jeden
sichtbar aber ich mache das ja auch für
mich denn meine Küche ist meine
wohlfühleroase und da muss es natürlich
schön aussehen und da darf ich auch pink
dekorieren und da kann man gar nichts
sagen dann haben wir hier unten meinen
Schrank da habe ich
meine Tortenständer drin meine Glashaube
mein tortendrehteller der ist da
hinten klar ich muss zwar hier jetzt ein
bisschen das wegnehmen um ans hintere zu
kommen aber irgendwie muss ich ja den
Schrank optimal nutzen und das ist ja
dann kein
das rauszuholen hier habe ich meine
tortentransportboxen für meine K
Kuchenform und hier die Runden und hier
habe ich in meinem zweiten Unterschrank
einfach meine auflaufforen und meine
Backbleche und das sind jetzt z.B meine
Steinprodukte habe ich euch ja auf der
Messe gezeigt auf der meinarktsmesse da
war ich ja am Stand von The pamperchef
und da habe ich mir einfach ein paar
Sachen bestellt weil ich die Sachen
richtig toll finde und ihr seht auch ich
benutze auch fleißig dazu werde ich auf
jeden Fall auch noch Videos machen weil
da auch schon viele danach gefragt haben
bald gibt's auch ein pizzavideo und das
backe ich natürlich auf dem Stein denn
ich habe noch nie so eine richtig
leckere knusprige Pizza gegessen wie auf
diesem Stein und ihr wisst ja ich bin ja
immer ganz gerne auf Messen unterwegs da
schaue ich immer nach neuen Geräten oder
einfach nach Dingen die mir meinen
Haushalt und meinen Alltag erleichtern
und ich versuche natürlich immer alles
wovon ich überzeugt bin und was mir
gefällt in meinen Shop mit aufzunehmen
aber es gibt natürlich auch Produkte die
ich sehr gerne mag und sehr gerne
benutze die ich aber nicht in den Shop
aufnehmen kann wie z.B die Sachen von
tupware oder von The pamperchef das sind
ja beides direktvertriebe und da könnt
ihr einfach nur dran kommen indem ihr
dann z.B auf eine tuper Party geht oder
auf eine Vorführung von The pamperchef
oder ihr könnt euch die natürlich auch
nach Hause einladen ich finde beides
toll ich finde gerade wenn man sie zu
Hause hat dann kann man das alles mal
ausprobieren und austesten und die
persönliche Beratung ist da einfach sehr
wichtig du hast Thermomix vergessen
Thermomix genauso weil da gibt's einfach
diese Handgriffe die man wissen muss
oder die Pflegeanleitung oder eben alles
mögliche und das könnt ihr einfach nur
über die direkte Beraterin dann
mitbekommen und finde ich einfach klasse
aber natürlich schade dass ich nicht
anbieten kann aber dort könnt ihr es
dann eben bekommen hier ist sch meine
Arbeitsfläche also hier stehe ich immer
und koche hier schneide ich meine Sachen
oder Rolle auch Dinge aus wenn ich ganz
viele große Sachen ausrollen muss z.B
Fondant oder Plätzchen oder so mache ich
das hier auf meiner holzarbeitsfläche
aber hier ist so mein Bereich deswegen
habe ich mir das ja auch so geplant dass
ich direkt hinter mir das Waschbecken
habe falls ich hier was habe dass ich
gleich nach hinten kann und hier ist
eben alles so
eingespielt ich zeige euch jetzt einfach
mal was ich hier rundherum in meinen
Schubladen habe ich habe so bisschen
getrennt hier habe ich mehr so meine
kochsachen da drüben meh so meine
backsachen und ich zeige euch jetzt
einfach mal die Schubladen und so ein
paar Systeme ich habe hier z.B in meiner
obersten
Schublade unser Besteck und zwar ist das
ganz hier links oben aus dem einfachen
Grund hier kann man es rausnehmen und
direkt in ins Esszimmer rüberlaufen und
das ist einfach so ein großer
Besteckkasten der war in der Küche schon
mit dabei ich habe hier unser normales
Besteck dann habe ich hier aber auch
meine Messlöffel und meinen Messbecher
die ich ganz oft zum Backen brauche hier
ist Sam miras Besteck und hier habe ich
so mein Servierbesteck wie Salatbesteck
und so weiter und ich brauche immer
Stifte in meiner Küche immer Pflaster
und immer Klebeband und deswegen habe
ich das hier auch mit dabei und
natürlich auch meine Fernbedienungen
hier die für meine Dunstabzugshaube und
für meine Lichter und bei mir geht's
jetzt auch hier wieder von oben nach
unten je nachdem was ich oft brauche ist
oben was ich nicht oft brauche ist unten
da muss ich mich nicht so auf Bücken in
der zweiten Schublade ups habe ich mein
Kochgeschirr und hier habe ich solche
Einteiler drin damit das Ganze so ein
bisschen Ordnung behält hier habe ich
z.B meine Teigschaber ich weiß ich habe
viele aber ich brauche auch viele große
und kleine und dicke und dünne ich liebe
teigschabe also das ist so mein
Lieblingswerkzeug in der Küche da oben
habe ich ein paar Pinsel sind alles
übrigens Silikonpinsel ich bin so froh
dass es die gibt und dass es diese
ekligen Haarpinsel nicht mehr gibt weil
die einfach immer Haare verloren haben
und Silikon ist echt Goldwert wenn man
den richtigen Pinsel hat und richtige
Silikon und das richtige Silikon dann
habe ich hier meine Schneebesen da habe
ich auch relativ viele weil ich aber
echt auch viele Schneebesen brauch vor
allem der Kleine ist mein
lieblingsschneebesen den habe ich so
gerne weil der eben auch so ein bisschen
fester ist und mit dem weiß nicht mit
dem verrüre ich ger meine Eier und so
weiter das ist echt so mein
lieblingsschneebesen und da ist Hal pink
schon
klar dann habe ich hier noch Cups also
cupbälter habe ich auch bei mir weil ich
auch gerne mal was amerikanisches
ausprobierere und dann arbeite ich eben
mit den Cups und wieg mir das dann ab
und so weiter hier meine Eislöffel und
Eisportionierer mein
plätzchenptionierer der ist von Küchle
hier habe ich mein kochwerkzeug
hier meine löffelablagen die ich sehr
praktisch
finde und hier meine Zangen und
natürlich eine suenkelle und das ist
einfach ihr seht ihr ich habe nicht viel
Kochzubehör also ich find es nicht so
mega viel ich habe einfach das was mal
am wichtigsten also was am wichtigsten
ist und was ich am meisten brauche aber
heute geht's nicht um mein Zubehör
sondern um die Einteilung über mein
Kochgeschirr und über mein Werkzeug
werde ich ja noch ein Video machen ich
weiß ich habe es schon sehr lange
versprochen dass ich mal dieses
gerätevideo mache was finde ich gut was
finde ich nicht so gut ich habe auch
alles gesammelt in zwei Kisten was ich
nicht gut finde aber ich möchte das
Video einfach gut machen und will mir da
einfach ein bisschen Zeit lassen und das
KitchenAid Video kommt auch noch
versprochen nächste Woche nächste Woche
ich wollte es einfach nicht schnell
schnell abdrehen müssen es kamen einfach
so viele andere Videos dazwischen und
deswegen verzeig mir bitte
schön hier habe ich dann wieder diese
Einteiler drin und habe da auch so
kleine Schälchen mit dabei das war
einfach alles von dieser schmidtküche
mit dabei und hier habe ich so meine
backsen also mein kleines mein kleines
Backzutaten Sortiment hier habe ich
meine backgewürze ich finde das nicht
optimal sortiert weil es nicht so gerade
drin steht wie ein Soldat
und einfach hier meine Bindemittel also
Gelatine oder agatine mein Backpulver
meine
Aromen also alles hier
reinsortiert und jetzt in der untersten
Schublade habe ich meine Öle und mein
Essig und da habe ich einfach auch drauf
geachtet hier so ein Einteiler
reinzumachen damit ich hier mein Öl habe
und meine backtrendprays und hier meinen
Essig habe und das ist auch ganz wichtig
denn wenn ich koche habe ich einfach die
Schublade geöffnet die steht dann links
von mir und dann kann ich da einfach mal
alles rausholen und irgendwann wieder
zumachen und muss einfach nicht
weglaufen wenn ich Öl oder Essig brauch
hier habe ich auch diese Einteiler drin
und habe da meine kochblumen noch drin
und noch meine fallziebe und deswegen
sind die auch so toll weil ich habe
jetzt hier drei fallalzebe drin wie
passen schon drei falzebe in so einen
kleinen in so eine kleine Spalte rein
eben nur wenn man die hat die man dann
eben zusammenfalten kann ist halt echt
praktisch und hier habe ich noch mE ein
stmixer mit dabei in dem Koffer und noch
das Zubehör dazu da gehört auch dieser
Akku rein den ich jetzt vorhin gerade
aufgeladen habe dann habe ich hier
unsere Teekanne und am Anfang hat mich
das sehr gestört und ich habe mich bei
meiner Freundin immer gefragt wieso hat
sie immer ihre Teekanne auf dem Herd das
sieht doch irgendwie total blöd aus aber
es ist einfach so wir benutzen die
dreimal am Tag nämlich morgenens zum
Frühstück dann zum nach dem Mittagessen
dann noch zum Abendessen oder danach wir
sind einfach total die Teetrinker und
eigentlich wäre es ja Blödsinn wenn ich
die Teekanne jedes Mal wieder in den
Schrank Räume und sie dann zum Gebrauch
wieder rausnehme DAF brarauche ich ja
total viel Zeit also lasse ich sie
einfach auf meinem Herz stehen und
mittlerweile steht hier kan auch mein
Wasserkocher denn die induktionsfläche
lässt ja das Wasser so schnell kochen
dass ich gar kein Wasserkocher mehr
braucht deswegen habe ich im Hintergrund
auch keinen Wasserkocher mehr sondern
Koch mein Wasser direkt da drin und
deswegen steht die da und das ist eine
ganz hübsche die ist übrigens aus der
Türkei falls ihr nicht fragt und unser
Schleider der Deckel kaputt
gegangen ja und jetzt zu meiner
Schublade das hier ist jetzt meine
oberste Schublade und da habe ich
natürlich meine Töpfe drin ich habe bis
jetzt nur diese drei kleinen Töpfe von
Ikea aber das ist im Moment nicht
schlimm weil ich kann ja auch in der
Kenwood kochen also wenn ich jetzt z.B
meine Spaghetti bologese koche dann kann
ich die auch da drin machen oder alles
mögliche und deswegen beeilen wir uns
auch gerade nicht so mit dem Topf kaufen
ich habe auch noch nicht die Richtigen
gefunden und ja egal ich zeig's euch
weiter hier sind natürlich auch meine
metallschüsseln die ich brauche oder
meine
wasserbadbehälter und mein wogtopf und
so weiter und auch hier ist wieder so
ein abtrenner drin weil ich hier einfach
die Deckel am außen lagern kann und ich
habe hier auch das wichtigste Gerät
meine digitale Küchenwaage ich kann zwar
auch die Waage da oben benutzen aber
diese digitale ist natürlich viel
genauer wenn ich z.B ein biskitteig
mache müssen es vielleicht mal 25 g von
irgendwas sein das kann ich natürlich da
oben jetzt nicht so genau machen aber
eben mit der digitalen und hier ist
einfach wichtig dass man nicht zu viel
aufeinander stapelt dass man nicht
ständig alles rausräumen und wieder
Reinräumen muss sondern dass man
ungefähr mit ein zwei Handgriffen
Entschuldigung direkt an die Sachen dran
kommt habe ich jetzt dein Fuß
eingeklemmt so und da unten habe ich in
meiner Schublade schon wieder ein paar
tuberbehälter und zwar sind es meine
großen Schüsseln meine Salatschleuder
und natürlich die Servierschüsseln für
Salat und so weiter also das ist mehr so
dieses dekorative wo ich eben Sachen
anrichten kann also das
anrichtegeschirr dann kommen wir hier zu
meiner weiteren Schublade die ist jetzt
rechts von mir und da habe ich jetzt
meine Messer und so weiter drin auch
absichtlich weil wenn ich am Herz stehe
kann ich rechts mit der Hand direkt die
Messer rausholen und hier habe ich jetzt
wieder diese Einteiler drin und habe
hier z.B meinen schäller oder mein
Besteck womit ich einfach Gemüse und
Obst putzen kann da oben habe ich kleine
Messer hier habe ich so ein
Messereinsatz für große Messer damit man
sich einfach nicht schneidet und damit
alle gerade drin stehen hier habe ich
die Scheren drin hier sind meine
Paletten also Winkelpalette und
streichpaletten die sehe ich dann auch
alle auf einen Blick und hier rechts
habe ich noch meine Microplane meine
meinen zitruspresser meine feine Reibe
und hier hier meine Teigarten die sind
dann hier schön
übersichtlich in der zweiten Schublade
habe ich wieder Werkzeug da sind z.B
Sachen wie hier diese
schneideräder hier ist so
Servierbesteck hier habe ich die habe
ich ja mal benutzt für meine
zimtröllchen und diese
Schillerlocken oder ich habe hier noch
eine richtig coole teigarte das ist das
kann man auch gut benutzen zum
glattstreichen von kanach aber das zeige
ich euch irgendwann mal ja und einfach
Sachen hier sind die ganzen Öffner also
Dosenöffner Nussknacker Korkenzieher
alles mögliche hier mein Ananasschneider
und natürlich meine
Schneidegeräte ich mein Shop und das ist
jetzt z.B der Alligator den ich in
meinem Shop drin habe einmal in
Edelstahl und in Plastik und ich
empfehle euch beim Alligator immer die
Edelstahlvariante die ist natürlich
teurer als die Kunststoff Variante ist
ja klar aber sie ist auch deutlich
stabiler die Kunststoffvariante ist zwar
gut und auch praktisch vor allem der
kleine den liebe ich einfach aber mit
dem Edelstahl bekommt ihr selbst richtig
hartes Gemüse wie richtig harte Karotten
perfekt durch und warum ich den
Alligator habe und nicht mehr diesen
nicizer kann ich euch einfach in meinem
Tools Video zeigen wenn ich eben meine
Geräte
Vergleiche hier habe ich noch mal eine
andere
Schublade da habe ich diesen normalen
Besteck Einsatz drin und das sind jetzt
Sachen zum Anrichten also das sind jetzt
so Behälter von tuware die sind z.B
damit ich darin Vorspeisen machen kann
oder Nachtisch so ein Nachtisch habe ich
ja mal gemacht dieses
pfefferminzdessert ja das sind einfach
so
Sachen und da unten nur noch meine
Schneidebretter hier noch bisschen
KitchenAid Zubehör und einfach ein paar
Glasschüsseln eins der wichtigsten Dinge
die ich bei mir in der Küchen habe ist
dieser Rollwagen das den haben wir von
Ikea gekauft und der passt bei mir hier
in diesen Raum wie perfekt und
angegossen ähm und zwar habe ich den
hier weil ich z.B so in den Vorratsraum
gehe und da meine Sachen Hool die lege
ich dann da rein oder was bei uns
einfach am wichtigsten ist das ist auch
unsere Briefablage also immer wenn
jemand bei uns in den Briefkasten
geschaut hat und nach Hause kommt ist
einfach so das war auch in unserer alten
Wohnung so die Briefe werden irgendwie
immer in der Küche gelesen und da habe
ich auch mal einen Artikel drüber
gelesen dass 80% des Briefverkehrs
einfach in der Küche landet weil man
einfach nach Hause kommt die Frau oder
der Mann steht in der Küche man
unterhält sich dort der die Küche ist ja
sowieso der Ort da trifft man sich
einfach auch wenn z.B Geburtstagsfeiern
sind und deswegen ist es z.B wichtig
dass ihr in der Küche einen Raum habt wo
ihr eure Briefe ablegen könnt denn dann
habt ihr einfach eine Ordnung drin ihr
wisst es ist da ich muss es bald
erledigen oder ich muss es nicht
erledigen das ist jetzt nur eine Werbung
die kann ich jetzt gleich wegschmeißen
aber das sind einfach so Dinge die mir
weiterhelfen und den Rollwagen kann ich
echt
weiterempfehlen ich habe euch jetzt
gezeigt was ich da drüben alles in
meiner Küche habe und wieso ich die
Sachen dort habe nämlich weil ich dort
koche und dort der Backofen ist und so
weiter und hier an dieser Fläche mache
ich gerne meine Motivtorten weil ich
hier einfach am Stück eine große Fläche
habe und deswegen habe ich hier in der
Schublade auch mein ganzes Motivtorten
Zubehör ich habe hier z.B meine ganzen
Farben in diesen Einsätzen mit drin die
kann ich nämlich herausnehmen und mir
einfach auf die Arbeitsfläche stellen
ich habe jetzt hier meine ganzen
pastenfarben dann habe ich hier so
kleine Einsätze die sind jetzt auch von
Ikea und hier habe ich meine trockenen
Pulverfarben drin oder meine Stäbchen
für Cake Pops oder einfach mein ganzes
anderes Zubehör und hier habe ich
übrigens ein
Rondell was sehr praktisch ist das ist
auch eins von The pamper Chef und hier
habe ich alles sortiert reingesteckt das
heißt also meine lebensmittelstifte hier
sind ein paar Pinzetten die ich brauche
zum Backen mein
Modellierwerkzeug einfach alles was ich
brauche das stelle ich mir dann wenn ich
Torten Backe einfach auf die
Arbeitsfläche und kann damit arbeiten
alles benutzen wieder reinstellen und
wieder wegstellen hier habe ich z.B so
ein doppeldeckel gemacht und zwar sind
unten Sachen die ich nicht oft brauche
sowas wie Blumen zuugehör und das was
ich oft brauche habe ich hier oder auch
hier in der
zwischenschublade hier liegen jetzt
meine silikonmatten und darunter habe
ich dann einfach meine ganzen
Spritztüllen Spritzbeutel ausrollstäbe
und das
war's und in der unteren
Schublade habe ich ein paar meiner
Backformen ich habe jetzt hier eine
Kiste von Ikea reingestellt und konnte
da jetzt meine ganzen eckigen Backformen
reinstellen wie muffinbgform oder
miniogleform oder mein auskühlgitter und
hier habe ich einfach noch meine
Springformen und meine abkühlgitter und
alles was so außergewöhnlich ist z.B
eine sternbackform oder eine
Herzbackform habe ich alles in der
Abstellkammer weil ich das einfach nicht
so oft brauche wie die ganz normalen
Formen und ich gebe euch einen kleinen
Tipp von mir alles was ihr innerhalb von
30 Tagen nicht braucht braucht ihr in
eurer Küche auch nicht aufzubewahren ich
stelle das dann alles in meine
Abstellkammer und alles was ich
innerhalb eines Jahres nicht benutze ich
habe ja auch saisonale Sachen wie
Weihnachtsdeko oder Valentinstag oder
irgendwas und alles was ich innerhalb
eines Jahres nicht brauche brauche ich
auch gar nicht und wir streiten uns da
heute noch drum gell um unser racklet
Grill dass wir eigentlich nur zu
Silvester benutzen und ich sag immer das
ist so eine Platzverschwendung mein Mann
sagt schmeiß mal weg gebe mal weg und
ich sage immer nee eigentlich ist doch
lecker keine Ahnung habt ihr ein raglett
macht ihr das auch noch zu Silvester
oder Weihnachten keine Ahnung und hier
habe ich jetzt meine letzten zwei
Schränke in meiner Küche und dann sind
wir fertig und zwar habe ich ja hier so
ein Barfach und da habe ich einfach ein
bisschen ein bisschen Deko drin nicht
zchen auflassen ne ich will lass die
Leute sehen bitte ich habe mir da halt
ich habe jetzt nicht alle Farben bei mir
im Shop bit nach rechts ich will dass es
die Menschheit sieht aber ich will das
doch erklären ich hab seht ihr diese
Armee seht ihr dieser ich bin ich bin ja
froh dass sie keine Schminkvideos macht
ja ich kaufe mir halt keine Lidschatten
und so weiter ich kauf mir
Zuckerstreusel die sind auch schön bunt
nee also ich habe halt hier ganz viele
Zuckerstreusel so viel braucht kein
Mensch also ich werde die wahrscheinlich
mein Leben lang irgendwie wann
irgendwann aufbrauchen und Samira hat
noch was davon aber ich wollte halt
jedes mal daheim haben und mal austesten
und die schönsten waren dann in den Shop
und die anderen benutze ich halt die
braucht man ja unbedingt hier unten habe
ich ja so eine offene Fläche und da habe
ich jetzt meine Keksdosen drin das ist
auch echt super süß ich kann da auch das
Licht anmachen warte das mache ich kurz
und dann sieht es richtig hübsch aus und
und das ist jetzt nicht einfach n
dekorativ sondern ich habe da wirklich
meine Kekse mit drin und kann die dann
hier rausholen und ein paar Kekse
vernaschen und dann einfach wieder
wegstelle nach Weihnachten die Dosen ja
weg bis auf die Cake ganz
rechts und hier unten habe ich noch so
ein paar
dekchen ich habe jetzt hier zwar meine
silikonmatten drin das sind jetzt z.B
die mit denen ich die zuckerspitzen
mache die stelle ich ganz bald vor habe
hier meine Muffin Wrapper meine
Muffinförmchen und so weiter aber ich
muss euch auch dazu sagen ich habe zwar
hier jetzt ein paar
Silikonbackformen aber ich bin echt kein
silikonfan also das erste was mich total
aufregt ist du wäschst die ab trocknest
sie ab legst sie hier rein und die
werden total staubig weil sie einfach
diesen Staub dann anziehen und der dann
drauf haften bleibt und ich hasse das da
muss man sie praktisch vom Gebrauch
wieder sauber machen und man muss
natürlich drauf achten dass D mal gutes
Silikon hat aber da rede ich jetzt gar
nicht drüber weil das kommt in meinem
Tools Video und ich habe einfach diese
Schubladen genutzt um das alles hier
reinzustellen also ihr seht das ist
jetzt ein Beispiel aus meinem Leben wie
ich mein Leben organisiere meine Küche
ist organisiert vielleicht habt ihr ja
auch noch andere organisationstipps die
ich vielleicht sogar noch besser machen
kann aber meine Meinung nach ist das
jetzt für meinen Alltag perfekt
organisiert ich habe alles da wo ich es
brauche ich habe in meiner Küche die
Sachen jetzt so organisiert weil ich so
ein fach vermeide dass ich Dinge zweimal
anfassen muss also z.B habe ich ja meine
Teigschaber hier direkt bei mir oder
meine streichpaletten rechts von mir und
da habe ich einfach einen kurzen Weg zum
Gehen und ich muss einfach nicht Sachen
zweimal anfassen um sie rauszuholen oder
um sie wegzuräumen und das ist eben das
wichtige deswegen müsst ihr euch die
Küche so einräumen wie ihr eben arbeitet
und wie ihr die Sachen braucht natürlich
darf die Arbeit das Ganze zu
organisieren nicht mehr sein oder nicht
aufweniger sein als die Arbeit selber
also beim Organisieren müsst ihr drauf
achten dass ihr da den Aufwand gering
haltet und wenn die Arbeit an sich aber
schon einfach war dann erledigt sie
einfach ohne sie zu organisieren ihr
habt wahrscheinlich gemerkt dass wir
unsere Teller gar nicht in der Küche
haben normalerweise hat man die ja auch
irgendwo im Küchenschrank aber bei uns
sind die im Esszimmer das Esszimmer ist
bei uns direkt jetzt hier um die Ecke
also nicht direkt hier in der Küche mit
drin sondern wir haben so ein offenen
Wohnbereich und ich habe jetzt meine
Teller dort und kann sie dort dann
direkt auf den Esstisch machen manche
sagen das ist ein bisschen kompliziert
weil eigentlich kann man ja auch hier
schon Servieren in der Küche da muss man
die Teller holen aber für uns ist es
ganz praktisch weil wir ja dort essen
und ich serviere mein Essen meistens
immer am Esstisch und klar muss ich dann
die Teller von dort aus wieder hierher
bringen und hier einräumen in die
Spülmaschine wieder zurückbringen aber
für uns ist das kein großer Aufwand das
ist ja kurz gemacht aber wenn ihr dazu
neigt dass ihr z.B nach dem
Spülmaschinen ausräumen die Teller
einfach hier in der Küche stehen lasst
und sie hier zwischen lagert dann
schafft euch lieber den Platz hier in
der Küche damit Sie gleich wegkommen und
jetzt sage ich euch noch ein paar Zahlen
und ein paar Fakten die wirklich ganz
interessant sind nehmen wir mal an jeder
Mensch wird im Durchschnitt 75 Jahre alt
dann verbringt jeder Mensch 23 Jahre mit
Schlafen und während dem Schlaf
verstluckt der Mensch acht Spinnen sech
Jahre unseres Lebens verbringen wir
damit am heimischen Tisch gemeinsam mit
unserer Familie zu essen meiner Meinung
nach ist es viel zu wenig weil ich will
viel mehr Zeit mit meiner Familie am
heimischen Tisch verbringen 1,5 Jahre
unseres Lebens verbringen wir damit in
restaur zuessen manche sogar länger weil
sie länger auf das Essen warten
müssen z Jahre verbringen wir in der
Badewanne und 3 Jahre im Badezimmer für
mich ist es nürlich ganz unverständlich
W man mehr Zeit im Bad als in der Küche
verbringen kann 8 Monate verbringen wir
damit ungewünschte E-Mails aus unserem
e-mailposteingang zu löschen 1,45 Jahre
verbringen wir am Telefon odne natürlich
WhatsApp und SMS 140 Tage davon
verbringen wir in der Warteschleife bei
manchen Anbietern wahrscheinlich das
Doppelte oder dreifoche nur 11 Tage
unseres Lebens lachen wird sind gerade
mal 6 Minuten pro Tag das waren jetzt
nur ein paar Fakten und Zahlen jetzt ist
ja bald Weihnachten und jetzt kommen
wieder die geschenkezeit alle wollen
wieder das schönste Geschenk machen aber
ich gebe euch den Tipp verschenkt doch
einfach eure Zeit verschenkt doch einen
Gutschein wo drauf steht ich verbringe
Zeit mit dir oder ich schenke dir meine
Stunden oder bastelt etwas oder backt
etwas das finde ich viel viel schöner
und viel sinnvoller und spart einfach
eure Zeit also spart was ich eben vorhin
erklärt habe spart eure Zeit im Alltag
ein und verbringt diese Zeit effizient
mit eurer Familie und ich habe da jetzt
noch drei kleine Tipps für euch wie ihr
das machen könnt ihr könnt z.B eure
Aufgaben im Alltag aufschreiben und dann
nach der Dringlichkeit sortieren so
mache ich das z.B wenn ich weiß ich
möchte heute ein Video drehen dann steht
bei mir ganz oben auf meiner To-Do Liste
Video drehen danach vide schneiden
danach veröffentlich danach kommen
Facebook Kommentare und so weiter und so
weiß ich einfach was ist das Wichtigste
das erledige ich zuerst und was ist am
wenigsten am wenigsten wichtig das kommt
zum Schluss der zweite Tipp ist macht
euch eine not to do Liste bei mir heißt
es z.B wenn ich gerade etwas Backe oder
ich gerade ein Video drehe oder Video
Schneide heißt für mich dass ich nicht
auf mein Handy schaue nicht bei
Instagram reinschaue nicht bei Facebook
reinschau weil mich das einfach total
ablenkt gerade diese sozialen Netzwerke
und dafür nehme ich mir lieber am Ende
des Tages oder mitten am Tag irgendwann
mal so geballt eine Stunde Zeit und
macht es dann und den restlichen Tag
über versuche ich nicht ganz so oft
reinzuschauen weil das einfach ein
totaler Zeitkiller ist und dann gibt's
noch eine Theorie von Eisenhauer man
kann sich eine Eisenhauer Matrix machen
also eine Tabelle machen und da könnt
ihr eintragen wichtig und dringend und
wenn ich jetzt Aufgaben habe die wichtig
und dringend sind muss ich die natürlich
zuerst machen dann gibt's Aufgaben die
vielleicht wichtig aber nicht dringend
sind oder die dringend aber nicht
wichtig sind und dann könnt ihr
entscheiden muss ich alle Aufgaben
selber machen oder kann ich auch
Aufgaben verteilen z.B kann die Samira
bei mir die Spülmaschine ausräumen mein
Mann den Müll runtertragen nein kann er
nicht wieso weil ich kann jeden Tag den
Müll raustragen aber jeden zweite ja
das und ich kann das Essen kochen und so
kann man das einfach aufteilen und dann
sind alle gleichzeitig fertig ganz
wichtig damit ihr in eurer Küche schnell
fertig werdet ist dass ihr beim Arbeiten
immer sauber arbeitet das heißt wenn ihr
z.B ein Teig gerührt habt und der Teig
im Ofen ist dann putze ich in der Zeit
schon mal alles fertig und wenn ich dann
nämlich fertig gekocht und fertig
gebacken habe sitzen wir einfach
gemütlich am Tisch und ich kann essen
weil wer kennt das Gefühl nicht man
sitzt dort und isst was und dann hat man
eigentlich gar keine Lust mehr irgendwas
noch zu putzen und so sind wir einfach
ganz schnell fertig ich weiß nicht ob es
bei euch genauso ist oder ob ihr
vielleicht die Arbeit zum Schluss habt
und lieber sagt ich ess lieber schnell
also ich mach's halt gern so dass alles
fertig ist und dann habe ich einfach ein
ruhiges Gewissen und habe fertig bin
fertig und habe meine Ruhe ich hoffe
euch hat dieses Video gefallen und ihr
konntet ein paar Tipps mitnehmen
vielleicht habt ihr auch selber noch ein
paar Tipps die ich meinen Zuschauern
noch mitteilen kann dann schreibt es mir
unten in meine Kommentare rein ich würde
mich auf jeden Fall ganz sehr drüber
freuen wie gesagt meine videoankündigung
habe ich ja schon gemacht nächste Woche
startet meine Weihnachtsedition da kommt
auch noch so ein kleines Video dazu als
Vorschau und ich hoffe einfach dass ich
euch helfen konnte euch ein paar Tipps
geben konnte und dass es euch einfach
ein bisschen weitergebracht hat ich
wünsche euch noch einen ganz schönen Tag
und wir sehen uns dann beim nächsten Mal
wieder bis bald tschüss